okay so very excited to um to be here
today to share with you what I've been
working on so before I really jump into
things I thought I would give a sense of
sort of what the style of uh of work
that really gets me excited
um which is really about the potential
to leverage emerging technology to
improve people's lives while working on
interesting technical problems so this
coincides pretty well with the
communities and
topics that I consider so they being
autonomy specifically for roadways
intelligent transportation systems and
learning for decisions and control
so I'm gonna Now remind you of something
that we use every day and thus it's easy
to take for granted sometimes something
that we actually rely on uh for just you
know a lot of our our lives so roadways
are you can think of them as the
circulatory system of the economy they
bring producers to markets workers to
jobs students to schools sick to the
hospitals and so on and so forth so
they're critical they're critical piece
they are at the same time they're far
from perfect and so there's a lot that
we can do to improve these in all sorts
of dimensions
so the approach that we've been taking
for the last 20 years as to how to
improve roadways is what we might
consider something like autonomy driven
design so this is the idea that if you
can achieve autonomy if we can achieve
autonomy then vast societal benefits are
going to be unlocked so the reasoning
goes something like this let's figure
out perception planning Common Sense
reasoning social orientation altruism
and maybe a few other things and then we
can use this to make roadways more
sustainable and by more sustainable I'm
going to restrict the definition here to
mean that roadways are safer cheaper
cleaner okay and it can mean a lot of
other things as well
so as you might know from there not
being any of this in the in actual
roadways this was harder than we thought
so let me recap a bit as to this this
sort of phase of autonomy driven design
where we are why we thought this was a
good idea and what we can learn from it
so I'm sure many of you have seen this
before this is the Gartner hype curve
this describes the life cycle of a
technology which includes the hype the
hype stage which is when expectations
for this technology are inflated
um so there have been multiple waves of
hype for roadway autonomy this is not
the first this is probably this is
perhaps not the last
but this sort of started this wave sort
of started and kicked off with the DARPA
Grand Challenge an urban challenge of
which Stanford has had immense history
around 2005 and something like a decade
later we start seeing articles of this
flavor this is a Business Insider piece
titled wide adoption of self-driving
cars could be only five years away okay
so that didn't happen a few years later
we had the very unfortunate Uber
self-driving car crash which struck and
killed a pedestrian Elaine Herzberg
causation or car or correlation I don't
know but it's coincides with a lot of
the dip then in the hype for autonomous
driving
here we are today still somewhere in
this in this area
so roadway autonomy has sort of been
through a lot and I want to sort of
recap why we thought this was a good
idea and again why what we can learn
from it the rationale for roadway
autonomy really does have its merits so
let's review this
the first motivation is safety
so there are something like 43 000
fatalities on U.S roadways this is from
2021 and there's this very famous study
from nishta that concludes that about
that human error is involved in about 94
of these fatalities
so it is very hard to conceive of an
approach that would really get us to
like zero deaths without removing the
human from the equation okay so that's
argument number one the second one is
cost so I don't know about you but I
could use a 25th hour in my day a bunch
of studies conclude that Americans spend
about an hour on the road okay so you
know one thing we could do is well we
could all hire taxi drivers that's very
expensive
so travel time is by far the largest
component of cost in the transport of
people and goods throughout the country
okay so autonomy could potentially you
know do something about that cost Factor
third being the environment and there
are many more along these lines along
the lines of externalities
so the transportation sector is the
largest contributing sector of
greenhouse gas emissions in the U.S at
this point at around 29 and a vast
majority of these emissions about 80
percent are on roadways
so autonomy could enable all sorts of
efficient use of vehicles that could
accelerate electrification it could
enable sharing of vehicles potentially
integration with Transit because smooth
traffic flow it could help everyone use
the right size of vehicles platooning so
all sorts of these benefits
so
this was the reasoning let's build
autonomy and then we get sustainable
roadways the question is in the premise
it's not really clear if this first
piece is sort of you know
technologically ready
so I'm going to argue that sustainable
roadways at this point having given this
sort of a few Decades of time to develop
may require a different approach
so for lack of a better term I'm going
to call this use-driven design so the
way this works is let's consider what we
want to do in terms of improving
roadways and then let's design for that
so the logic is a bit flipped let's
start with sustainable roadways on the
on the left hand side and ask you know
what do we need in order to enable this
sustainable roadways and you know if if
indeed it requires autonomy then you
know we're sort of stuck where we um
started out but if not then we might be
able to make some progress okay so it's
a question of autonomy is sufficient but
is it necessary
so I'm going to look at a relaxed notion
of autonomy and specifically I'm going
to look at the coordination of vehicles
this is something that autonomy enables
but potentially you don't need all of
autonomy to do this okay so you might
need planning you might need some degree
of altruism a few other components but
you don't need the full full thing that
is what we think of as autonomy okay and
the question is does the coordination of
vehicles by itself enable us to achieve
more sustainable roadways if so then the
full thing of autonomy was you know
sufficient but not necessary and if not
you know so this is what this talk is
going to focus on this coordination of
vehicles
so the um the rest of the talk is going
to be as follows I'm going to sort of
talk one at a time regarding how
intelligent coordination of vehicles
could achieve cheaper Mobility cleaner
Mobility safer mobility and and so on so
along the way there's going to be a bit
of a detour because these intelligent
coordination problems these sort of
multi-aging control problems are
annoyingly hard to solve and so we also
had to take a detour in order to sort of
improve on these methods a bit
okay so I'm gonna first I'm gonna jump
into the first part which is on um sort
of Cheaper ways to achieve intelligent
coordination for sustainable roadways so
this is Joint work done with my students
Junction Siri and Mary and my
collaborator Roy dong at UIUC so this
sort of has a couple pieces but I'm
going to focus on the average case
performance analysis and I'm just going
to touch a little bit on the worst case
stability analysis
okay so a very cheap way to coordinate
Vehicles is to Simply give drivers an
app this is like much less of a
requirement than full autonomy if you
look at this in the spectrum of the SAE
levels of autonomy from zero to five
with zero being fully manually driven
cars to level five fully autonomous cars
we could think of this as something like
level 0.5 okay so the car doesn't even
have to have any level of intelligence
we just need a smartphone in the car and
this we might think of as probably the
lowest cost near near-term form of
autonomy that we could possibly have
and the question is then you know what
can this do so what we know from my work
as well as others is that with level
five sort of full autonomy we can
achieve system level improvements even
with a fraction of cars that are
equipped with this level five autonomy
we can analyze these traffic scenarios
and see that by optimizing a fraction of
cars we can see system level
improvements in terms of speed and
throughput okay so this is sufficient
level five is sufficient is it necessary
and the way we can analyze this is we
can sort of slice this along the
Spectrum and ask okay is level four
sufficient is level one sufficient and
so on and so we're just going to go all
the way to the other end because it's
sort of appealing that it is also very
low cost
um okay so this brings us to the problem
of
um what we call coarse grain control so
the question is to what extent can
guided human drivers achieve the same
kind of traffic optimizing behavior of
autonomous vehicles you can think of
guidance as like a dynamic speed limit
sign that's potentially even
personalized to individual vehicles and
drivers or similarly on the acceleration
side
okay this is not like you know a command
this is a sort of speed limit the driver
can still maintain safety in and whatnot
um so we consider this very simple model
of course grain control just piecewise
constant guidance so some speed held for
some time another speed held for some
time we're going to keep that um that uh
that time sort of constant so this is
also known as zero order holds with a
hold length of some Delta seconds and
the goal is to design these coarse grain
control laws Pi sub Delta and the
question is how coarse can these
instructions be such that we still
achieve traffic optimizing Behavior so
we can see that there's a whole thing
that we can consider different problems
with hold lengths like very very high
frequency Holdings like 0.1 seconds all
the way to sort of instructions that
update every 40 seconds and so on one
end of the spectrum you have sort of our
model of an autonomous vehicle
instructions that are sort of changing
so quickly a human cannot respond up to
a point where you know it's within the
realm of work that instructions that
humans could potentially follow and and
so we're sort of just borrowing from
some human factors research about eight
seconds is in the ballpark of why humans
can respond to and we're engaging in
we're designing some user studies now to
confirm it for our setting
so the specific setting um or to be a
bit more concrete about the setting
let's consider a traffic scenario
different networks where a fraction row
of vehicles are guided and one minus row
are not guided and just recall all the
vehicles are human driven now the guided
Vehicles follow some actions from this
learned controller pies of Delta where
the action updates every Delta time
whereas the unguided vehicles follow
instructions according to a conventional
driving model
so keep in mind now that the guidance
type the hold length and the traffic
scenario each is its own
multi-agent control problem
so we solve this family of control
problems by just independently
learning these control laws using deep
reinforcement learning and in some cases
we can analyze the stability as well of
the course grading system
so I'm going to jump right to the
results and then go back and talk a
little bit about the methods so let's
look at this model highway so this is a
circular track this is sort of like the
cart pull of traffic so it's like a
simple environment where you would want
your your stuff to work before looking
at something more complex
so a few observations are sort of nice
here so the core screen Guidance the
zero order hold actually coincides well
with what's called sample Data Systems
and so there's a body of theory that's
used to analyze these systems and so in
particular these the offenov kosovsky
functionals actually allows us to derive
sufficient conditions for system
stability for simple systems like this
okay so we can gain some intuition on
whether or not the system should you
know completely fall apart from a
stability standpoint now on the
empirical side this is an easy problem
in a particular sense there is a fixed
velocity that is optimal so in principle
you could hold whatever length you want
to okay so here we have the hold length
on the x-axis and the performance on the
y-axis so again on on this end we have
the AV on this end we have you know more
human like driving
so we expect the performance to you know
decrease over as the whole length
increases but in this case we should
expect a straight line okay so we have
the Optimal Performance here which is
better than some baseline here and what
we see here is that yes there is a
constant velocity that can maintain the
speed throughout however when we issue
some kind of acceleration based guidance
what we see is actually it's still
possible to to do to do like almost just
as well even up to 40 seconds however
when we apply sort of vanilla
reinforcement learning we see this hint
of brittleness we see that it's actually
a very very Jagged this training curve
and keep in mind that the only
difference between say this this problem
and this problem is just the hold length
the scenario is the same the guidance
type is the same so it's a very very
small change to the environment and you
know training with reinforcement
learning with our hyper parameter tuning
and whatnot it's it's actually rather it
was actually rather disappointing for us
um and so this actually motivated us to
develop a method which we're calling the
temporal transfer method and this is the
idea that this sort of leverages the
idea that these problems are more or
less the same okay the only difference
is this is this hold length so the idea
is that for some Target hold length we
should be able to find a policy we
should be able to solve a different
problem and then sort of if it's
successful transfer the result to this
problem
so we're going to leverage sort of two
ideas here one is that the these recall
these problems are all more or less the
same but the coarser the problem the
easier it is to solve because the
shorter the effect of horizon okay there
are fewer decisions you have to get
right for for the same amount of time
um so easier to solve you can think of
that as reducing the variance in
training however because the
instructions are coarser this may
introduce some bias in particular that
the Optimal Performance could be lower
okay so what we're exploiting here is
that there's some sweet spot there's
some sweet spot where the performance is
still just as good or good enough that
we can identify that sweet spot is
easier to train and then we can transfer
to the Target location Target hold
length so we can solve this using a
stochastic form of binary search to
identify this ideal Source hold length
so using these ideas we can then look at
more sophisticated settings so for
instance this highway Ram setting now we
sort of see the kinds of behavior that
we expect that on one end we have a high
performance from the autonomous vehicle
I should say red is without the without
our method blue is with our method so we
see sort of a higher performance above
some baseline and that performance
degrades as the hold length increases
which we expect but still for quite a
quite a bit of the um what's what we
understand now to be the human
compatible region there's still a
significant improvement over the
Baseline
so what we conclude here is that the
coarse grain guidance does preserve
benefits from autonomous vehicles in
terms of speed fuel throughput across a
variety of traffic scenarios the
implication is that these guided human
drivers could enable
near-term low-cost autonomy benefits and
that while a vanilla reinforcement
learning is brittle to even these very
small changes this temporal transfer
method can improve the reliability of
trading these coarse green control laws
yes
it's like have you studied like kind of
like a bus as to how many people we're
doing that work now yeah so we yeah we
don't have it yet but yeah we're doing
that work now uh it is important to um
to factor in the robustness aspect yeah
yeah maybe a related question what are
your thoughts on sort of the trade-off
between
um getting these this guidance to
drivers and the extent to which it can
draw attention away from the main
driving task if there's other things oh
I should speed up it's just low down are
you worried about some things yeah I
think there's a lot more that needs to
be explored there that's definitely
outside of my my wheelhouse what we can
do is we can actually analyze the uh
resulting trajectories and whether those
trajectories are safer according to
these surrogate safety measures so
that's something that we are starting to
do
um in a slightly different context
yeah absolutely
absolutely and should be dependent on
the environment and also we are also
thinking about making it adaptive like
based on the conditions the real-time
conditions right now it's just constant
so this is sort of like a very simple
model that we could analyze we have one
one axis where we can just sort of do a
first pass at this problem yeah I think
there's a ton more that can be done here
good okay so we're gonna um this this
like brittleness of reinforcement
learning was very disappointing to us
and so we took a detour to um try to
understand this problem
um and so in particular
um this is uh this is a couple uh it's a
it's a couple lines of work
um that we where we are asking is it
just us uh are we failing to use
reinforcement learning or is it specific
to our problem or is it reinforcement
learning like we want to tease about
tease apart like what the what the
challenge
um was and then some ideas as to how to
sort of go about resolving
um this sort of brittleness okay so this
is the brittleness that we observed and
what we basically did I'm going to be
very brief on this but we basically also
identified brittleness of deep RL in
existing benchmarks okay so staying
close to home there's this Benchmark on
traffic signal control controlling
signals not Cars
um and uh this Benchmark includes both
classical techniques as well as learning
uh bass techniques reinforcement
learning based techniques
and what we have done is we modeled
um like basically you can think of the
previous work as like okay when you vary
the environment a little bit the method
no longer works so we vary the
environment a little bit based on a
actual distribution of uh traffic
intersections with our partners uh Utah
Department of Transportation so we
modeled the sort of 160 intersections
from Salt Lake City and then all we're
doing is we're taking these methods and
we're re reevaluating them on this on
this like set of natural variations of
this task of traffic signal control
we're retraining on on each individual
intersection so we're not doing
generalization we're testing the the
robustness of the algorithm
what we find is that on a ranking from
best to worst while the reported was
reported in the original Benchmark is
that these learning based methods
outperform this like the most prominent
fixed uh prominent classical technique
of just fixed time control when we
re-evaluate on the natural variations
the fixed time control and the classical
methods together outperform all of the
learning methods
and there's no specific pattern in what
where what kinds of intersections the
the methods are failing in and I think
that requires um further work so for us
this is like not great news for
reinforcement learning but also tells us
that it might not just be us we also
then looked at this for the popular
control benchmarks like this half
cheetah and this pendulum and the this
cart pull and we find that sort of by
varying the the length of the pole and
the gravity coefficients and whatnot you
don't see as drastic of a flip in terms
of like oh we should have not use
learning anymore but we find flips in
terms of like which methods are
considered best
which reinforcement learning methods are
considered best okay so it's not just us
this sort of makes us want to throw
reinforcement learning out the window
but we do like some aspects of it so for
instance the learning based methods are
motivated by how rigid model-based
methods can be to the assumptions of the
underlying problem and so what we would
really I just want methods that work so
it's very natural to ask you know how
about methods that sort of try to
incorporate The Best of Both Worlds some
sort of more hybrid methods that can
both leverage the known problem
structure in a sort of model based sense
but also provide flexibility for the
difficult to model aspects like model
free and I think there's a ton of work
in this space but what we need is we
need this for our vehicle coordination
problems
so with this we need some kind of data
set of problems with natural variations
and we are painstakingly you know
creating some by modeling it with Salt
Lake City and and by looking at these
problems but there isn't sort of like an
imagenet that you can just sort of
download uh for studying this problem
systematically and that's a huge issue
here so we what we're doing is we're
we're faking a data set by looking to
discrete optimization which has
documented over decades very natural
variations of problems including certain
kinds of vehicle coordination problems
so this is sort of um this was this so
this area is a is a new one for me but
very very compelling and very
interesting so consider this problem the
vehicle routing problem this is like
Amazon's package delivery problem that
they solve every day and Uber's problem
and and whatnot so there are a lot of
there are a lot of vehicle routing
problems that are practical today this
problem has been studied for at least 60
years and this is a nice tree of sort of
the almost like the evolution of this
problem as the world evolves we realize
oh sometimes the vehicles have
capacities sometimes there are time
windows on when I need to deliver the
packages sometimes the vehicles are
electric and so these variations of
these problems have emerged over the
last 60 years that we have this sort of
data set of natural variations that we
didn't have to painstakingly come up
with but these are still open and active
research problems
so what we can do is then we can sort of
use this as a basis for trying to design
methods that are more robust to Natural
variations
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
leverage an already effective strategy
for many of these problems especially at
Large Scale which is called large
neighborhood search so the key idea here
is that large problems could often be
decomposed into small problems okay and
what large neighborhood search does is
that basically iteratively seeks a
better solution by re-optimizing sub
problems so here's a big problem we
identify a subproblem we solve it we
presume that we can solve a small
problem but we can't solve a big problem
or at least we can improve a small
problem and then we take the solution to
that small problem put it back into the
big problem okay and then we iterate
and what is typically done is that the
sub problem is selected randomly okay or
using a heuristic that's then customized
for the particular application
so what we're going to do is we're going
to learn these the promising sub problem
or sub problems to select okay and I'm
going to skip over all the details
there's a Transformer as a regression
problem and whatnot and Skip right to
the results
um so for the most uh commonly most
widely studied form of vehicle routing
problem which is the capacitated vehicle
routing problem fairly large problem
2000 nodes or cities we can see that
alerting approach can basically cut in
half the solve time so it could be twice
as fast as random sub problem selection
largely research itself is already very
powerful it already gives like a 10 time
speed up over not using large
neighborhood search okay
okay and then what we can do is we can
use that same algorithm and we can train
it again on variations of the vehicle
routing problem as long as you have big
problems that can be decomposed into
small problems and we we look
specifically at cvrp with time Windows
as well as with pickup and delivery and
we again see uh speed up so what's
happening here is some kind of implicit
learning of a selection strategy that's
sort of customized to these different
variations that at least outperforms the
random selection
so what we learn is that deep
reinforcement learning fails to be
robust to these natural variations
including very small variations like the
hold length of a problem
as well as the layout of the signalized
intersection the standard control
benchmarks and that this algorithm which
we call learn to delegate which is this
learning guided large neighborhood
search is more robust to Natural
variations of the vehicle routing
problem as compared to random selection
so we're extending this idea now to a
variety of settings which includes
different applications we're looking at
the multi-agent pathfinding problem in
Warehouse Automation in collaboration
with Amazon robotics we're looking at
different sub-problem types so rather
than which which specific subproblem to
improve which type of subproblem to
improve as well as different algorithm
backbones like branch and cut for
solving mix and major linear programs in
collaboration with MathWorks
okay so now I'm going to go back to the
main theme of sustainable roadways and
look at how we can use intelligent
coordination for cleaner roadways this
is the biggest project I've ever
undertaken and it's still ongoing and
it's sort of split into sort of modeling
pieces and control pieces which will be
evident
so let me remind you that we urgently
need to decarbonize transportation and
it is the largest contributing sector
so what I'm going to try to exploit here
is that traffic signals you can think of
them as a safety device we need them for
safety but they induce stop and go all
the time and basically everywhere
so it's about half of driving is near
signalized intersections and this back
of the envelope calculation I found very
helpful when I was designing this
problem but keep in mind this is very
back of the envelope I take a recent
survey for uh you know how much
emissions can you reduce by controlling
cars to mitigate emissions and I did a
very coarse meta-analysis I took the
plus minus one standard deviation of all
the studies reported in this survey it
gives the okay 6 to 28 percent of
emissions of CO2 emissions is
potentially avoidable
if you're optimistic and say let's take
the upper range this says that about 15
of CO2 could just you know not be used
not be not be emitted it's not doing
productive work
so what does this look like
um I just sort of demonstrating the idea
so with fixed time traffic control you
have quite a bit of queuing at the
intersection cars goes a complete stop
when they come to a complete stop they
have to fully reaccelerate alternatively
if you do some kind of what what's
called Eco driving you can guide the
cars in a way that when they get to the
intersection the intersection is green
they didn't come to a complete stop they
may be slowed but they don't have to
re-accelerate from stopped okay and
that's where the emissions gain comes
from
um okay so this is um the research
question here is wood coordinating
vehicles to reduce the CO2 at um at
intersections actually move the needle
on climate change mitigation goals maybe
it's a good idea but maybe it's very
niche in in terms of where it is useful
so this was a this was a curiosity to me
because when I started looking at this
um I this is this is actually called
eco-driving as signalized intersections
it's a bit of a mouthful but there are
some 50 papers on this topic already
starting from a decade ago but we don't
see any of it in practice and the
question is sort of why not is it not
worth doing like is it just not very
effective is this like a topic of
academic interest or you know is it a
missed opportunity
so the goal of this project is to
investigate not how to Eco Drive a lot
of the papers that a lot of the
literature focuses on sort of the more
detailed aspects of like for this
intersection for this kind of equipment
for this kind of assumption you know how
do we how do we implement eco-driving
but the question is should we should we
Eco-Drive is it worth doing we are
interested in thus what is the expected
Improvement of eco-driving over possible
driving scenarios the expectation
so um what's sort of fun is that as I
was doing literature review this first
reference here is titled eco-driving an
overlooked climate change initiative
published in 2010 this was actually
referencing highways
um and uh coincidentally you know
actually in cars there often are these
eco-driving modes for highways for
highway driving and it would be you know
amazing if if there's an analog then for
the other half of driving
okay so the central challenge of this
work is basically how diverse the
scenarios are so we can look at first
just the diversity of intersections
every intersection has you know a
different number of different numbers of
approaches different numbers of lanes
different turning restrictions and so
just the intersections layouts
themselves these are all factors that
affect eco-driving Effectiveness so we
have to consider this sort of family of
of scenarios and this is just the ones
that I can picture very easily there are
additional ones such as the slope of the
roadway which obviously would affect
eco-driving the weather conditions the
driving the travel demand vehicle types
and Age and and all this
so this is the central challenge
so his uh looking at the literature the
first challenge is basically that
eco-driving controller design has really
focused on specific settings so there's
no known approach that can
simultaneously handle this whole sort of
large family of considerations
um there's also no known approach that
will scale to what we end up with is
millions of of different scenarios so we
take a multitask a deep reinforcement
learning approach which I'll get into
more detail later the Second Challenge
which is really unfortunate is that
large-scale modeling of traffic has
really focused on highways at least in
ways that are available to academic
researchers and so we need to actually
do the modeling of the urban traffic
though the driving that's actually near
signalized intersections as well as
other eco-driving factors
so we do this modeling
it's it's a huge effort and in order to
do this in order to do this at scale
because keep in mind we are doing we're
still doing a rough analysis this is not
like for like implementation tomorrow in
order to do this at scale we leverage
open street maps which is great but if
anyone of if any of you have used it
you'd also know how terrible it is so
it's an amazing resource but almost all
of the attributes are missing okay so
all this like you know most of the speed
limits are not you know there most of
the lane lengths and turn configurations
and all of this stuff is just not there
and so we devised a data imputation
framework to impute many of the missing
quantities it's not perfect but it is
much better than just not having the
quantities
this is only the static aspect of what
needs to be modeled they're also
non-static aspects such as for instance
the percentage of vehicles that are
being guided the weather conditions the
season the the actual travel demand and
um and whatnot putting this together
this gives us about 1.5 million
scenarios and we were just to give you a
sense this 27 000 intersections is about
10 of the signalized intersections in
the country so
um and we chose the locations based on
high emitting areas as well as data
availability
so this is also not everything there's a
very extensive modeling effort that I'm
not going to like uh belabor here I have
highlighted just the aspects that we
discussed on the previous slide in terms
of the static aspects
what was very fortunate for us and what
actually allowed us to actually do this
project as a small academic team is that
many of the non-static aspects are
actually already captured by an industry
standard model maintained by the
Environmental Protection Agency so the
EPA moves model captures for instance
what is the emissions of a vehicle of a
different age in a driving on a road of
a particular slope of a particular type
of a particular at a particular humidity
and temperature
so all of this detail is really well
detailed in this model
this is an excellent tool it's main
challenge for us is again the scale
because we are working with a million
scenarios so um we computed that it
would take us about nine compute years
to analyze these scenarios by by sort of
directly using the tool but what
underlies the tool are emissions models
which are actually continuous functions
and so we engaged in this project to
basically reverse engineer this EPA
moves model and basically build we
learned surrogate models by fitting
neural networks to to this tool and
extracted the data to to do this
okay so this allowed us to scale this up
okay so now on to the control part we're
just going to optimize the acceleration
of vehicles okay the vehicles around us
can Lane change but just to keep the
problem a little bit more tractable
we're like the guided vehicles are only
going to be optimizing the acceleration
for the eco-driving purpose
okay so now we do our multitask
reinforcement learning what does this
mean
um so every traffic scenario every one
of the million scenarios is a task and
when we train we sample for each rollout
we sample a new task a new traffic
scenario and we you know add it to our
we use that data to train our policy in
order to make this not um totally silly
we provide not only the vehicle's
observations but we also provide some
information about that task to the to
the input of the neural network
we use very standard training practices
otherwise so standard algorithms
standard training protocols for this
this like shared parameter multi-agent
setting something that's non-standard is
that the reward function design is
really important given the brittleness
of reinforcement learning so we have
sort of several works that are just
focused on designing this reward
function
this itself doesn't work well because
very reasonably having one policy work
over a million scenarios is sort of a
tall order so we extend this just a
little bit to something that we are
calling multi multitask uh reinforcement
learning which is multitask
reinforcement learning on a partition of
the space this this partition is here is
sort of designed based on domain
knowledge we end up with something like
seven okay seven policies so seven
partitions which is still much less than
the original set of scenarios we're just
partitioning based on the number of
lanes and the phase the number of phases
in the traffic signal
okay so now on to the results so
the analysis here is for Salt Lake City
we're still crunching the numbers on the
other ones but what we see if we if so
everyone is adopting this
we see something like uh close to 11
reduction in fuel if we're comfortable
just scaling this to the city to the
country so we assume that
Salt Lake City's intersections are
representative of the country we get
something like 1.5 percent reduction in
sort of U.S level CO2 okay so what does
this mean to you I for a while didn't
know I tried very hard to find a
reference point and um sort of a gold
standard that I identif that I found is
from The Venture fund that Bill Gates
leads for climate change and they are
basically looking to support initiatives
that can achieve that could that has the
potential to achieve one percent Global
greenhouse gas emissions reduction so
this is in that ballpark which is to me
very exciting
I can also say that at around 20
adoption we see about point four percent
reduction in CO2 and this 20 gives us
about 28 of the benefit okay so there's
some non-linearity and the intuition
there is that if some vehicles are
eco-driving the vehicles behind them
even if they're not doing it themselves
might benefit as well okay
so we find that eco-driving at
signalized intersections could
potentially substantially contribute to
Transportation decarbonization as part
of this work we did extensive modeling
of urban traffic to fill a gap in
traffic modeling Beyond highways and we
developed these neural surrogates for
this industry standard emissions model
and this is this actually we found later
to be of a potential High interest to
air quality researchers because the this
tool is sort of the bread and butter for
these researchers but there's also a
very high learning curve for this moves
model like maybe one or two months to
learn how to use this and so potentially
easing the access to this
and then finally this multi multi-task
reinforcement learning actually allowed
us to scale up the analysis to a million
plus scenarios okay so okay so then I'll
I'll talk about this last part so this
last part is my first foray into safety
which I'm now finding to be such an
interesting area especially in the area
especially when it comes to especially
really looking at this for roadways so
this is work that was just published
actually like one or two weeks ago I'm
done with my two students
and okay let me talk about why the safer
challenge is so hard
the safer challenge is really hard
because the bar is actually really
really high human humans are just
incredibly safe so this is the statistic
for the US there's about one fatality
every 80 million miles this is like huge
this is eight nines of reliability in
terms of failure-free Miles this is
eight nines after the after the decimal
point in terms of this probability okay
for reference AWS is at about two nines
my Roomba is at about one nine
and for what about for autonomous
driving so here's the reference point
that we have waymo over the last 10
years has driven 20 million miles
they've driven that much okay
um it's really hard to put a number
therefore on autonomous driving you can
use proxies for this and the proxies
that I've seen put autonomous driving at
somewhere between two to four orders of
magnitude below human driving at this
point
so without some breakthroughs I think we
need to be creative about what we expect
from autonomy
okay so I'm going to try to be creative
and this is just the very first work
that we have in this this sort of
direction of safety which brings in
which takes inspiration from Air Traffic
Control
air travel is an even safer system its
record puts us at 10 nines even better
than the eight nines of human driving
okay so maybe there's some ideas that we
can borrow from this sector
and the idea is we're going to bring
ideas from air traffic control which is
so we think so you know aircraft we
there's this thing called autopilot but
there are no like autonomous like
commercial aircraft there are three
pilots in the cockpit there's air
traffic control on the ground we're
going to bring in some of these ideas so
let's bring these ideas for air traffic
control down to dense roadway traffic
okay roadways are much more dense than
the open Skies
and the idea here the central idea is
let's complement the autonomous
capabilities of vehicles with remote
supervision from expert operators so
let's not give autonomy full of
responsibility let's also not give
infrastructure the full responsibility
let's see if we can get the best of both
worlds
so I'm looking at a very specific
question right now
um so the question is right now we do
have a operator for a car so it's like a
one-to-one kind of deal imagine that you
were to take this operator and put it
put them him her into a call center
basically with a steering wheel okay
everything's perfect communication is
perfect something's perfect okay so
let's make all the clean assumptions the
question is in principle how many
operators would you need to uh to
supervise your Fleet safely at the
reliability of humans
at human now if it's one to one still
like that's not good like we just
incurred additional costs of all the
communication infrastructure and whatnot
so this is sort of the question as the
AV Fleet size grows how how does the
supervision scale okay so this is the
scalability of supervision problem so we
model this using a queuing
um using a queuing model so we can think
of arrivals to this queue as risky
events okay risky events that need to be
supervised and we have some number of
operators M uh that can supervise these
and we're interested in the probability
that you know there are so many risky
events that arrive that there aren't
enough operators okay so what you can
model this as is a queue without a
buffer so the buffer is exactly the size
of the number of operators so if any any
you know new risky event arrives it does
not receive service
so
um effectively we're interested in the
probability of service loss that's the
probability that the system already has
m m risky events okay and reliability
you can think of as one minus this piece
of M
okay and then now we can set that to our
nine eight nines or something
okay so specifically we're going to look
at the most the closest to practical
setting for autonomous driving which is
highways we're specifically going to
look at a dangerous maneuver on highways
which is merging okay we're looking at
merging on it can you can also think of
it as merging off okay so the first
thing to observe is that
um oh we're going to assume that once on
the highway the car can drive safely by
itself so we're just looking at merge
conflicts as our risky events so the
first thing to observe is that you don't
always need to supervise the vehicle
okay if there's no merge conflict sorry
okay
okay so if there's no merge conflict
then there's no need to supervise and
we're going to determine whether there
might be a merge conflict using
conservative worst case forward
reachability okay giving the operator
enough time to sort of uh understand the
scenario okay so in the interest of time
I'm going to be very brief on the
details the question is what happens
when adoption grows when AV adoption
grows so intuitively more adoption means
there are more cars that need to be
supervised so reliability goes down when
rely when more when there are more AVS
you also have more AVS that can sense
the environment and communicate you know
everyone's trajectories and whatnot so
the reliability goes back up at some
point that's these are these dipped
curves the even more interesting thing
is as you have more AVS these AVS can
start to coordinate
if you have two AVS approaching the
merge point and they're both AVS one can
just slow down and just let the other
one go right they don't have to collide
if that was the plan trajectory and as
you have more AVS the probability that
it's two AVS that are merging at the
same time becomes higher okay so these
reliability curves for the same number
of operators get shifted up with this
kind of coordination
and what we find through some numerical
examples we didn't cherry pick this but
we also didn't explore this extensively
is that it could make something like a
six orders of magnitude difference in
terms of reliability for the same for
the fixed for a fixed number of
operators
okay so this is like this is a
particular setting that is
um where 50 supervisors achieves the
eight nines of reliability whereas
without super without cooperation is at
like 99 and this setting corresponds to
a scaling of about 42 operators uh sorry
42 vehicles per operator and keep in
mind that the original the status quo is
this one to one
Okay so
that's all I wanted to say about this
this first four into safety I'm finding
this to be such an interesting area
there's so much more to to be done this
is to our knowledge the first queuing
theoretic model for supervision and
coordination of autonomous vehicles and
I think it's a really interesting
concept to start thinking about this
these relaxed Notions of autonomy
enabling sort of a richer design space
for for safer roadways
so I hope that this conveys convey to
you that autonomy is sufficient but it
may not be necessary for us to make
substantial progress on sustainable
roadways and that this idea of
use-driven design of considering what we
want to design for in the first place
and then deciding for it
um you know can bring us quite far thank
you
foreign
Kathy great talk uh I have a quick
question about the remote supervision
and coordination part that you were
talking about so the remote supervision
uh like
why um why do I I don't fully get like
why you actually need the remote
supervision and why you can't like get
the cars to just like do connected
vehicles and like communicate with each
other also like if you have a remote
supervision then what is the visibility
that they have right like they'll
probably like maybe I didn't get and get
some part of that like like I'd imagine
that it would be actually like kind of
hard to do yeah supervision
um so so I didn't get the first part of
your question like why not the yeah why
not just like like I thought like if you
just do the connected Vehicles like
angle and cooperate like you wouldn't
necessarily need remote supervision for
the type of yeah when basically we're
because the vehicle some we're we're
doing this with mixed traffic so the
vehicles may not be uh connected
and so as the
um AV penetration grows the probability
of the interaction with a vehicle that
is connected is gross and that's
actually that actually eases supervision
quite a bit so when there is
coordination then we don't have this
problem but when we interact with a
human driver then we have this remote
operator we're not assuming anything
about those vehicles uh then there's
there's no sensors on them and and
whatnot but for a practical like
implementation perspective in terms of
like field of view and inclusions and
whatnot there we I think we have to be
more creative about like where do we put
sensors potentially on the
infrastructure like on the on the
on-ramp and whatnot so that there is
full visibility to to the operator yeah
great question
so you talked about some of the
evaluations and like the simulation
environments but like have you guys
started looking at real evaluation for
like methods no no this is like the very
first um but are you envisioning doing
real yeah
it's a very good question
um I'm interested yeah but I think we
are still pretty early yeah that's
interesting yeah happy to talk about it
if you're yeah
so
is it Mike is here
um something
um you know kind of relate to this
real evaluation I'm kind of curious
um
how how do you envision this
um sort of translating into something
that autonomous driving companies that
are starting to do sort of early
prototype deployments could learn about
it my understanding from the early waymo
prototypes is that once they started
having these cars saying you know the
Phoenix Phoenix area
um
that were driverless actually they
didn't have a car and you know the
person could get picked up and dropped
off basically at first they had a
chaperone car following you know just a
few meters behind in case anything
happened so that they could quickly jump
in and you know whatever resolve issues
um obviously that's not very sustainable
and you still probably want to have some
kind of supervision is this is this
something that you're thinking could you
know allow this to to actually scale
actually have people on the road doing
this kind of following uh how how do you
think about that okay very good question
um okay so one thing that's helpful in
this concept is that this is basically a
fixed location this is like the the
on-ramp
okay so you could have it could be
scalable in terms of supervising in
terms of like
um additional supervision like right at
the on-ramp or right at several on-ramps
let's say
um so I think that's part of it I
haven't thought about this at all so
this is just like on the Fly
um on the Fly thinking
um in terms of coordination with in
terms of um okay so let me give let me
back up a bit and give a bit of context
for like where this idea is sort of
coming from this wave of autonomy has
been this like autonomy driven so
autonomy then do things and this
autonomy is sort of assumed to like
require no no
um support from infrastructure and
that's sort of what a lot of the
companies like really would like
um the previous wave of roadway autonomy
was basically infrastructure based this
is the California path project and there
the issue is that it required basically
a dedicated Lane of the highway
to fulfill this this automated Highway
scenario using technology that was
already more or less mature 30 years ago
but we could not justify the economic
cost of either building a whole extra
lane or reducing Highway capacity by a
third or whatever to facilitate this new
technology that would have zero almost
zero cars on it at most times and so
where I'm coming at here is okay it's
it's clear it has to be done in mixed
traffic it can be a dedicated
infrastructure
can we get away with a different kind of
infrastructure communication
infrastructure and can we complement
where autonomy is now where with
um with you know infrastructure support
in a cost-effective manner to Envision a
concept for automated highways that's
sort of where this is coming at and I
think that there are a lot of
interesting questions at the sort of
testing and realization of this I think
that where I am right now I think
there's still so much to conceptualize
even at this at the at this higher level
of like designing the system sizing the
system figuring out whether this concept
could see the light of day
um and so that's where that's where I am
now and that's potentially why I don't
have responses to all the lower level
questions but I think a little bit about
the you know like whether 5G 6G is like
sufficient to support this kind of thing
and stuff like that
cool
I
think
yeah I have a question um also like uh
evaluation of like the first uh work you
talk about like uh the you you mentioned
about user studies uh are you doing this
with
um like just the guiding uh stuff is
that with real drivers yeah and I guess
that the question is do you foresee any
fairness issues with with this kind of
uh instructions like if you personalize
this kind of guidance the driver might
think
um I'm like sacrificing something like
my uh drive like like time for for
others like uh dude yeah this is a
little bit different yeah so yes we're
doing this with actual drivers and two
we in collaboration with some uh some
folks and we are also doing the the
equity aspect is I think is a little bit
different from routing games so with
routing games it's like okay uh people
participate and the people who are
willing take the longer routes and
they're really sacrificing their travel
time for the benefit of others this one
we're not changing their routes they're
basically getting there at the same time
as everyone else we might even be able
to leverage something like carbon
credits to compensate for those who
participate if you know that were to
work out so I think there is a realm in
which the equity aspect could even be
Progressive as long as they have a
smartphone
yeah they have a car and smartphone
I'm sorry to do this we're going to need
to really push the room uh if there are
more questions we can take them
thank you so much
[Applause]